this makeup game from the rain out last
week tigers are going to send out
right-hander matt manning for his 17th
start of the season he had a no decision
in his most recent start a week ago
today against these very same white sox
he gave up three runs and four hits
three walks and two strikeouts and five
innings of work chicago has two men
aboard three houses
this is probably the last guy you want
to face in this situation the way he's
been swinging the bat
big pitch runners go 3-2 strike three
called throw to third and got him i'll
strike him out throw him out down goes
grondal out is garcia thanks to the seed
from eric haas dallas geico on for his
30th start
he's been durable not gonna strike out a
lot of guys not gonna walk a lot of guys
the left-handers have hurt him this year
which even he can't figure out now the
most popular tiger miguel cabrera 38
years old he's only 16 hits shy of 3 000
to the right side and a base hit miggy's
got real good numbers against kykel
partly because
kykel isn't going to just blow him away
first and second two away jamer
candelarios switch hitting third baseman
leading the majors with 42 doubles and
the 3-1 pitch
is hit in the air out into the left on
the move and making the grab is jimenez
in the corner
for the final alleys are hernandez in an
rbi spot with two outs
got him looking that works too
down goes cesar hernandez the number
nine hitter and willie castro
on the ground to short garcia on the
charge had to double clutch and it cost
him
he was gonna go to second goodrun got
down the line well and then by the time
he decided to try and get out willy
castro castro moves too quickly and
everybody's safe turns the lineup over
for akil badu
badu to left field
that's down one run is home
all the way to third goes willy castro
badou's in with a sliding double detroit
gets a run because of the bobble
at shortstop and it's one nothing jose
abreu leads off the chicago fourth the
one two swing a line drive to right
field hit it hard coming in grossman
he'll dive and make the catch
he's kind of leaned down made the catch
fell to the turf he knows he has to
charge hard to his left and he stays
with it you got to have the focus on the
baseball all the way into your glove one
down it brings up grand all grand all
caught looking on what ended up a double
play
2-0 serve as hit in the air deep left
center field badou's back at the wall
it's gone
it's a home run for yasmani grand all
and we're tied at one
he was going to drive the ball to the
big part of the park and with the wind
blowing the way it is today take
advantage of the conditions good job
yasmani bases loaded in a 1-1 tie one
away the pitch to hernandez is hit in
the air
down the left field line it's going to
drop it's a fair ball
jimenez will score here comes monkatta
vaughn will be held at third as castro
kind of overran it had to chase it down
and foul territory
hernandez has a double
and the white sox lead three to one
still only one out two in scoring
position and the batter is zach collins
zach rips this ball to right field and
this will bring home to andrew's home
cesar follows on a two-run single for
zach collins and it's five to one one
outrunner at first batter is luis robert
luis robert into left center field but
due's not going to get there neither is
castro and they clang off of one another
so here comes zach collins he is on his
way with run number six
and luis robert is now
the seventh straight sox batter to reach
willie castro leads off the bottom of
the fifth ball hit in the air to center
back on it robert still tracking
he's got it on the warning track
nicely done luis robert that ball was
hit a ton by willie castro
oh it was only hit about 4 15. so wasn't
enough
needed to be 420.
great job as robert cruz back and made
that grab brings up jonathan scope
singled in the first and bounced back to
dallas kykel in the second
hammers one left field
back goes jimenez still going back he's
out of room and it's gone jonathan scope
goes yard for the 21st time this year
and the tigers are within four
jonathan scope has been so good this is
a fastball out of his zone but he hasn't
seen many fastballs from kykel and he's
not wasting it gets his hands
and keeps him on top of the baseball
ian crowe gets a souvenir out there
a couple of base runners and the batter
will be willy castro another 2-2 a fly
ball to left it's deep but it's playable
and alloy is there and he's got it
tigers fail to score they strand two
brings up jimenez who's two for two and
has been on base
all three times
takes a big rip and wallops this
baseball that is a good sign eloy
a two-run shot here in the seventh and
it's eight to two well you could tell as
soon as that one left the bat
that was gone this time he got
every bit of that
and that is a blast
into the pen
432
feet happy feet if you will here's
cabrera one for three singled in the
first inning this one is ripped into the
left field corner by miguel cabrera that
bounces up against the wall he's going
to dig for two on his way and he's got
it a leadoff double for miguel cabrera
hit number 2
900 and
wright will face issac paredes
who walked in the second
hit aligner to shorten the fourth and
struck out swinging in the sixth
the 1-1
oh and it hit him fastball then you see
him getting hit on the right forearm and
that's not how you want to take a pitch
you talked about rolling away from the
pitch and right there
isak
is basically diving into the pitch it
hits him
right on the bone there he'll stay in a
ball game derek haas with the bases
loaded and nobody out
to left field all the work it will work
one run is home
here comes candelario paredes got stuck
between second and third that's all
right he's into third base safely thanks
to the two run single
from erikas and the tigers get a little
closer nico goodrum all for one with two
walks
down the right field line
that's into the corner
paredes trouts home haas is hustling
home hits the bag at third he is there
and nico goodroom
first belly slide into third vegas we
got a ball game
tigers trail at eight to six
oh you gotta love it you gotta love the
way these guys keep battling we're just
a fly ball right jack just to get
another run home the o2 is swinging the
fly ball right field and it's going to
be caught by vaughan back to tag goodrum
he will score without a throw sacrifice
fly
tigers are within one eight to seven
a walk a line out two double plays
hole for three
for brayu
two strikes
and he hit him
oh and that hit him right on the elbow
that one got him
now tony larussa came out of the dugout
somebody just got thrown out
yeah
looks like miguel cairo
grand dahl takes a ball in the dirt and
jose peels away throw down to second
mates in there and he is out well he
went in real hard to goodra and goodrum
is jawed adam and jose is going right
back at him jose is really not happy
with being hit by that pitch and now the
benches are going to clear at comerica
park
garrett crochet is right in the middle
of that thing the sox and tigers in
their final game of the season in the
ninth inning everybody's spilling out
from the bullpen and meeting at second
base i'm not sure why lang was in the
middle of that but jose is justifiably
unhappy that's the most unhappy i've
seen him socks are an out of way goodrem
two-run triple last inning he took it
right down the line in right field
called strike three think liam hendricks
is happy sox win 8-7 your final
you